dollar general's business model it's a
retailer that can make a lot of money
selling very cheap goods to a relatively
small number of people
if you've ever shopped at a dollar
general you might have found the store
on a remote road like this one
it has every appearance of being in the
middle of nowhere but this is a
meticulously planned
very well thought through strategy a
strategy that's been key to dollar
general success
in rural america the company is bucking
current retail trends
by expanding rapidly and opening stores
away from population centers
dollar generals go where walmart's
aren't but it's not just the strategic
locations
far away from big box stores dollar
general employs a number of tactics to
keep operating costs down
including leasing stores paying
employees low wages
and selling limited products and yes
that includes stuff that isn't really a
dollar dollar general is almost
something unto itself it kind of takes
pieces from
a lot of different retailing models this
is the economics of
dollar general after more than 30
consecutive years of sales growth
dollar general has become one of the
most profitable and fastest growing
retailers in the us
last year the company brought in more
than 30 billion dollars in sales
so how has a store that sells products
at rock bottom prices
managed such extreme growth they add
about two and a half stores every day in
the united states
just for scope there's more than four
times as many dollar generals as there
are
walmarts there's more dollar generals
than there are mcdonald's in the united
states
there are currently more than seventeen
thousand dollar generals in the u.s
but if you don't live in rural america
you might not have ever even stepped
foot inside the store
where would you typically find a dollar
general uh you'd you think of a two-lane
road
think of you know places where the
houses are far apart
farmlands kind of lower income
communities you might find them by a
post office or a church or
at an important intersection this is
often a deliberate decision
the company has formulas for identifying
locations to open stores
often the dollar general will be down
the road miles away from the nearest
town and walmart areas with limited
shopping options
three-quarters of dollar general stores
serve communities of 20 000 people or
less
according to the company it looks for
need first and foremost so it's going to
look for a place that we might call a
food desert where there are not
there's not a grocery store there's not
a big box store
it's kind of target demographic is
households with people making forty
thousand dollars or less
and it looks for a place where it can
get inexpensive real estate
to keep costs down dollar general tends
to lease their properties rather than
buy them
and inside the stores it has a limited
selection of products that it buys in
bulk
which gives the company more buying
power with suppliers
most dollar general stores don't offer
fresh produce
and compared to grocery stores have less
perishable items
which have a shorter shelf life and
bring in lower margins
you walk into a dollar general you're
going to see
metal shelves it's going to be quite
bare bones
think linoleum think you know think
bright lighting
you won't see a lot of people working
there
by paying low wages to a minimal often
part-time staff
the company keeps labor costs low the
median annual
income for employees is just over
sixteen thousand dollars
according to dollar general dollar
general says they employ more than 157
000 individuals and that they offer
employees competitive wages
and benefits these stores are staffed at
minimum levels so there's not
there aren't many employees they pay
closer to a gas station attendant than
even a walmart
employee so it's people that much like
their customer base
people who live in an area where there
aren't a ton of other options
despite the name not everything costs a
dollar but prices are extremely cheap
and often significantly lower than
grocery and drugstores critics say
dollar general strategies harm local
communities
by not providing healthy food options
and potentially hurting the local small
business economy
dollar general says that they are not a
grocery store and that they are serving
customers that would otherwise
not have access to an affordable retail
option ultimately the low prices
and the convenience for rural customers
is what keeps people coming back
some shoppers have even found items for
under a dollar
any shopping at dollar general let's go
the first store i found propel water for
one cent i always use the dollar general
app scan and verify it's a penny before
heading to the register
dollar general is on pace to continue
growing the company grew
16 during the pandemic a time where
other retailers saw growth in e-commerce
not in-person shopping dollar general
plans to open about a thousand stores
this year
and when you have a business model that
involves small
footprint stores without a lot of
embellishments or bells and whistles
a company can do that quickly and they
can do it cheaply dollar general is also
branching out and going in new
directions
it's been experimenting with stocking
more fresh and refrigerated food
and moving towards urban centers it
plans to expand pop shelf
a new chain aimed at higher income
suburban customers
pop shelf in addition to being located
in different places
it'll aim to sell things that are more
think of more fun so not
not as much staples that you need to get
by day to day but
things like decorations party supplies a
little bit more fun
than necessary dollar general says the
new expansion
isn't necessarily a shift from their
overall growth strategy
they say they can serve a diverse
customer base with stores in urban rural
and suburban locations yet even as
dollar general expands its offerings and
target demographics
the company expects that its core
customers will continue to be shoppers
in small towns without other options